soit pour le Maroc ou la France pour le
Maroc a pour le Maroc
combien moi je dis quand même de 1 pour
la France à ton avis on va gagner ce
soir
je veux qu'on gagne mais je pense que le
Maroc va gagner je suis pour la France
mais je serai plus content s'il me gagne
tu es pas la France ou le Maroc
non
il y avait d'autres supporters
le premier truc auquel il pensait
c'était pas le football regardez c'est
qui ton joueur préféré c'est soirée pour
moi
elle veut pécho papa
il est trop beau Fernandez j'ai pas
envie de dire des trucs mais tu es trop
boire landaise avec le pécho toi non il
pêcheur
dans tous les sens ah ouais toute
l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
alors on était notamment dans une fan
zone où il y avait une très très belle
ambiance regardez devant la Marseillaise
[Applaudissements]
regardez l'ambiance après le premier but
regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'ambiance pour la 2 le deuxième but
elle est encore pire regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le 3 joueurs dans la surface de
réparation il est capable de dribbler
trois joueurs de une cabine téléphonique
Daniel comme la distance on est tombé
après le match on est tombé sur Houssine
lui il faut le savoir c'est le Clos
d'Alexis de wish regardez le mec se
démonte pas regardez c'est quoi tes
pronostics à toi
ça va être
3-0 pour la France
[Musique]
pour la France
[Applaudissements]
alors forcément c'est la folie partout
regardez l'ambiance place de la
République à Paris regarde
après la victoire on a pu faire la fête
mais aussi faire des rencontres non
programmées c'est quoi ton prénom Anna
Anna allez parle-moi
non c'est pas grave moi c'est alia
enchanté
on a rencontré la supportrice qui peut
passer d'une émotion à l'autre en un
quart de seconde imagine tu es français
et
tes marches quoi
mais j'ai pleuré mais là je suis
contente mais genre je pleure et je suis
content
mais je suis trop contente quand même
mais je suis trop triste on a aussi
rencontré celle qui a annoncé
officiellement à ses parents qui a
loupera l'examen de demain
[Rires]
on a rencontré aussi un autre festival
minerveuse mi heureuse quelqu'un de
nerveux tu as dit quoi on est en finale
ou pas bien sûr que oui
on a aussi rencontré un mec qui
visiblement c'est trop pédément
merci pour tout merci vous êtes
incroyable et on a également vu une
séquence qui ne pouvait se passer que
pendant la coupe du monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et enfin on termine avec des supporters
qu'on a suivi toute la soirée qui
visiblement sont fan de l'équipe de
France et dafida Turner
[Musique]
voilà les demi-finales là on a une crier
marmous de Mahmoud
merci Hafida on t'aime à plus tard
aussi
c'était la folie
en direction des Champs-Élysées pour
fêter la victoire tu vas faire quoi sur
les chambres ça va fêter ça la victoire
la finale ça on est là on est tombé sur
un supporter qui danse quand il est
heureux on aime bien on s'en va ou alors
on est aussi tombé sur des supporters
qui aiment plus TPMP que le football et
c'est pas pour nous déplaire
[Musique]
on est tombé sur un supporter français
qui visiblement un grand problème
d'autorité je félicite les Marocains qui
ont parfaitement rentrer
sur une supportrice qui a mélangé le
foot la gastronomie et surtout l'alcool
j'adore la
couscous j'ai également vu des gens très
heureux qui n'arrivent pas à se
canaliser 2022
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et d'autres supporters très heureux mais
qui eux se canalisent trop pour le coup
vous êtes qu'au temps de la France
[Applaudissements]
elle revient très très fort sur les
Champs-Élysées les mecs nous ont régalés
aussi regarde
sur les Champs-Élysées on est tombé sur
des supporters qui ont réussi à faire
disparaître un journaliste en deux
secondes
on est on est on est en finale
on est tombé sur un supporter anglais
qui aime le foot et la boulangerie
et un autre supporter qui aime le foot
et la coloscopie ouais
[Musique]
on a aussi croisé ce supporter en plein
meeting sur les Champs-Elysées vive la
France vive la république j'adore ce
pays
j'adore ce pays on a aussi croisé cette
autre supporter à qui on souhaite
d'aller chez le coiffeur avant la finale
inch'Allah
sur les Champs-Élysées on a aussi croisé
beaucoup de gens qui avaient un peu de
mal à communiquer avec nous
[Applaudissements]
on est aussi tombé sur un supporter qui
a un problème avec les pronoms indéfinis
[Musique]
et on finit par un supporter qui avait
une petite pensée pour vous Siri
[Applaudissements]
pense à moi je t'aime c'est bien beau tu
rigoles
merci à tous
[Applaudissements]
prochainement incroyable et c'est
incroyable le Giroud
c'est fou
français avec quel chroniqueur il
souhaiterait regarder la finale regarder
les réponses sont incroyables regarde
la France est champion du monde la
première c'est qu'est-ce que vous ferez
le plus fou et deux si vous voulez le
fêter avec un chroniqueur TPMP ce serait
qui ici même heure Gilbert dez
avec quelle chroniqueur de l'émission tu
voudrais faire la fête tu voulais dire
chroniqueur ou chroniqueur oh monsieur
est philosophe on essaye alors
Daniel Daniel est très sympa Daniel
Moreau avec Raymond comme ça on klaxonne
dans son camion à klaxon et surtout les
Champs-Élysées tous les Champs-Élysées
avec valouche Valérie oh Valérie Benaim
ouais pourquoi ça va me faire un bon
couscous
bien sûr sans 10 sur 10 belle là
direct
dimanche c'est la France est championne
du monde vous pouvez fêter ça avec un
chroniqueur de TPMP vous choisissez qui
la blonde la blonde la blonde comment
elle s'appelle même elle est jeune
Daniel Moreau
gros bisous
je les adore
c'était incroyable
non t'inquiète Daniel ils veulent aussi
les champs dimanche
j'aimerais enfin qu'on se quitte sur ce
dernier match Tito qui prouve que qu'on
soit français marocain franco-marocain
on est tous ensemble ça fait chaud au
cœur regardez ce beau magnéto ce beau
message regarde
c'est pas grave on a perdu mais vive la
France vive la France
[Applaudissements]
dans mon gars je voulais que le Maroc
gagne mais je suis ravi que la France
gagne je suis quand même française et
bientôt la victoire on espère et essayer
d'avoir des polémiques Maroc ou la
France je pense que les Francs communs
ou les Marocains français ils sont très
heureux de ce qui se passe faut pas
essayer de leur faire faire un choix je
suis fier de mon pays je suis contente
du parcours qu'ils ont accompli
maintenant moi je suis franc comme un
requin et vive la France
[Applaudissements]
on est on est des frères et soeurs on
est en fait des humains des Français des
Arabes des noirs des tout le monde tout
le monde tous les fachos qui disaient
ouais il va y avoir du bordel sur les
Champs-Élysées les Marocains les
Français vont se taper il y avait des
bordels il y a pas de bordel il est où
le bordel il y a pas de bordel on est au
génie tout va bien
il y a pas de racine c'est nous
2016 mais Cyril Hanouna je vous adore
c'est gentil mais j'ai un message pour
pour Jean Messia mais il est raciste les
racistes
[Applaudissements]